I hope you guys are hungry it's taco
night special request alright we are
back with another cooking video today we
are making chicken Tinga we have a
special request by Isaac this is his
favorite they have been made at this
household and this recipe is in no way a
traditional authentic Mexican recipe so
I'm gonna make a very quick and easy
very inauthentic chicken Tinga today
alright so the first thing we'll need is
a whole onion we're going to spice it up
so Isaac really likes this dish you
typically request this at least a couple
times in the Oh onions in my eyes all
right next up we have a green bell
pepper I'm gonna take off the stem the
seeds out now if you want to add some
heat to your chicken Tinga definitely
substitute this bell pepper for two
jalapeno perhaps the most awesome thing
about this dish is the fact that it's a
one pot recipe so everything goes into
one pot so minimal mess minimal
dishwashing all right so we're gonna add
a little bit of oil and when your oil is
hot add your peppers and your onions
we're going to dice up some garlic
alright let's go ahead and add the
garlic make sure to keep stirring the
peppers and the onions to avoid burning
alright next we're gonna add some spices
to the mix first is chili powder will do
two tablespoons of chili powder this is
gonna give you that essential Mexican
aroma I also have it I'm Joe chili
pepper powder we will do one tablespoon
of this one so all together you want
three tablespoons of chili powder two
teaspoons of cumin and now we're gonna
mix it all up we're gonna toast all the
spices into the vegetables and through
the heat we're gonna bring out all the
flavors and this is where it starts
smelling real good next add one 28-ounce
can of diced tomatoes I guess you could
offer the fresh tomatoes too but it just
takes longer to cook to get those
tomatoes stewed alright so from here
we're gonna add the star of the show our
chicken and we're just gonna put old
chicken breasts in here three chicken
breasts and I like to work in the sauce
to cover the chicken it's working those
flavors together
teaspoon of salt got a spoon I'm gonna
that looks about right and lastly I have
a vegetable broth here you can use
chicken stock or you can use water if
you don't have vegetable or chicken
broth and what you want to do is we're
braising this chicken submerge your
chicken as much as you can
I also like to throw in a little bit of
Mexican oregano just to give it a little
bit more of a complexity to the flavor
profile I didn't measure how much that
was but let's just say we want that much
alright so bring your pot to a boil
cover and turn on the heat and let it
simmer for 20 minutes 20 minutes later
and this is what this looks like
mmm you could really smell the chili
powder the cumin the ancho chili powder
all right so now we're gonna transfer
these over to this bowl once they've
rested for five minutes we're gonna
shred our chicken take two forks and
have at it now what we have remaining
here is this tomato broth and that we're
gonna reduce that into a sauce now to
help us do that we're gonna make a corn
starch just luring two tablespoons some
cornstarch and some water and now use a
fork and mix up the cornstarch into the
water now we're going to add that
cornstarch slurry again you want to pour
and stir at the same time as soon as it
gets into the heat the cornstarch is
gonna thicken and that's what's gonna
give it the creamy texture that we want
for the sauce
[Music]
and while the sauce is huh I like the
top run off with some cheese you can
honestly use any cheese you like but I'm
using the mozzarella so what I had in
the fridge because I forgot to get the
Mexican blend now take the same two
forks and you want to work in the sauce
into the chicken and into the cheese
that cheese hmm
see that cheese pulling is beautiful all
right me Familia is home I hope you guys
are hungry it's taco night special
requests so how do you guys like to eat
your tacos some cheese you know what we
don't do it the authentic Mexican way
which is to heat up yes and it's below
the stove we don't do that all right
already told everyone that this is not
an authentic recipe because then they
come out nice and soft when you do
on the stove they all hard and crispy
and that's not something I like I don't
like your hands washed
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how much sauce hot sauce you put I mean
I guess for you focus on those
[Music]
[Music]